[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
aaron wilson covers the texans for the
houston chronicle kind enough to join us
on uh
short notice aaron uh update us on
when these allegations were first made
public with desean watson
just two days ago dan tony busby
uh who unsuccessfully ran for mayor and
it's a member of the texas family board
of trustees very prominent lawyer very
wealthy lawyer
he filed the lawsuit he announced it
first as unusual on instagram
saying that the lawsuit had been filed
it had not been filed was filed
the next morning the previous to that
the head in fact i was told sought money
the woman that made the first allegation
that deshawn watson had
sexually harassed her etc in a massage
and
all the details have been outlined in
the lawsuit
but that was the timeline so after that
happened
then subsequently he files it in harris
county district court
and it only cost me 325 to file a
lawsuit
and the allegations are made there's no
documents the text message of allegedly
an
apology after their exchange
and that's not present i don't know if
that will happen at discovery if it
in fact exists if it does so there's
you know that and you know deshawn
reacts to it
on social denies doing anything
disrespectful to anyone it's basically a
blanket statement
and what's now happened is after the
initial one he's asking for anyone else
to come forward
and that he hasn't filed the second
lawsuit that's what happened yesterday
so he comes out with a second lawsuit
alleging that deshaun watson
flew in a woman from atlanta to meet him
at
the estonia which is a very fancy spa
and hotel and
kind of like a place that you know the
rich folks in houston hang out it's a
kind of
a country club aspect to it and
you know alleging that there was this
you know
different type of situation different
massage but different woman
and so now he's saying he has six
and he's going to file six lawsuits is
what tony busby has stated on
instagram and so we're expecting another
filing
today and he says this one will be um
you know have
some you know a lot of you know
obviously
you know very salacious details uh
kind of like the last one which i
thought was you know very
uh you know graphic uh in nature
and some of the stuff that's kind of
like hard to repeat
just on a family radio show but yeah it
was a you know definitely a very raw
portrayal and again only allegations all
unproven
all civil my understanding is that never
ever was where the police called
no allegations were made to you know
to try to make it a criminal matter and
like deshawn said my understanding is
it's been a you know money grab from the
start
especially with the first alleged victim
jane doe both of these are going to be
jane doe's they'll all be apparently
jane doe's
there won't be a name attached what
about the
what about the football side of this so
aaron the timing of this we have the
draft coming up
uh next month you have the possibility
of
desean not playing for the team tyrod
taylor gets signed
uh is this all coincidence that it's all
kind of converging right now and
what's this do for the so-called trade
market
for deshaun watson right there have been
a lot of conspiracy theories
on social media about the timing
including tyrod taylor you're being
signed hours before
my understanding is that is coincidental
because they always intended to
address the quarterback position the
way it affects trade value is if there's
an nfl investigation
they have really when you look at
the nfl uh you know their response
yesterday was no they're just they have
no comment on it
and you know so they're not in a stage
where i think they're doing anything
they may never do anything they may just
view it as a civil matter that they
don't want to
you know address it could be handled
that way it could be handled in a
different way depending on
how they feel about it what's the
outcome you know if what if he settled
you know what would happen would they
then look at it as something like well
is that an admission do we need to look
into this more
should they monitor everything in terms
of the trade market
the teams are still interested i know
that for a fact
and that has not changed would it change
the terms
no but if they were to get to a point
where they're negotiating the texans are
just
in a listening mode and or telling
people
you know no we're not interested they're
still steadfast and not
him and he will not play for them again
he is
made that unequivocally clear dan that
he has no intention to ever play another
down that's the way he's put it to
friends
for the texans he's really intentional
in that and he told david cully that
uh so you know that's all been
communicated
do you think that he's traded if he's
traded it's before the draft
i think there's a very good chance that
he could be held on to
and yeah i wouldn't be oh and if i
wouldn't assume anything it's a moving
fluid situation it makes the most
logical sense and everyone knows
that the value is the highest and then
you know what the picks are
if you do it later if you do it in 2022
then it's not the same kind of terms and
it does set as i've been told many times
a terrible precedent if a player can you
know essentially force himself out
and i would not rule out the texans
playing hardball
can you but can you put it in simplistic
terms here aaron
what is desean watson's problem with the
franchise
is it on the field or off the field
it's off the field that his trust in
them
and his feelings about how
business was conducted and the state of
the franchise
and his interactions obviously with the
owner cal mcnair
and him feeling that he was going to
have input it's not one thing
as i've been told many times it's a
culmination of
all those things affecting his
you know trust in the organization and
how he feels about the organization
so it's not just one thing there's so i
would say the last is sort of
finding out on social media that's kind
of the straw that broke the camel's back
then but it's not a situation where you
say
man that's it no it's just finding out
about the andre hopkins trade on social
media basically not being consulted
that's i would say one more thing he
just didn't feel like he was being
treated like a partner
of the organization they feel like he's
being treated just like a normal player
in some cases so
that you know bothered him and
it bothered him to the point that he
requested the trade and that's where
they are and that he's been
steadfast in that and he's not budging
not an iota well i know you got a lot of
work ahead of you
uh aaron we appreciate you joining us
and uh thank you
thank you so much that's uh aaron wilson
he covers the texans for the houston
chronicle